hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
a short but very interesting discussion
on the part of de Kurt takes place in
part 5 of his discourse on metaphysics
and it has to do with the relationship
between human beings animals and
machines and this this comes out of a
long tradition of of saying that that
human beings are fundamentally different
than the other animals in that we
possess rationality and because of
possessing rationality we exist at a
higher level than than they do and this
can be parsed out in many different ways
Descartes introduces another wrinkle
into this which makes good sense given
his metaphysics in talking about
machines and why does he bring this in
what what's the context here so he's
actually discussing in part 5 a book
that he didn't publish called the world
and he's telling us about the different
things that he went over in that in the
course of that discussion which is quite
long and we're not going to get to most
of it he tells us about how he was you
know setting out for us a theory of the
relationship between body and mind or
brain body and what at that time they
were calling the animal spirits and the
view that they had in the physiology of
that time is that there were various
fluids we can call them that moved
around in our body call the animal
spirits and these were largely
responsible for sensation consciousness
in terms of the body itself not not in
terms of the mind but in terms of the
body's contribution to it movement
affections all those sorts of things now
we don't actually use that anymore we
talk instead of you know biological
processes that are chemical or
electrical but it's really the same idea
that there's we've got a body part of
that body is the brain and there's all
sorts of things going on with
various systems and then these produce
the states of consciousness that we have
so he says that you know I I had
explained all these matters I'd shown
what structure the nerves the muscles he
must have in order to enable the animal
spirits to have the power to move its
members he talks about which changes
must occur in the brain to quest states
of waking sleeping dreaming how light
sounds smells tastes all other qualities
can imprint various ideas through the
intermediary of the senses how hunger
thirst and other internal passions can
transmit ideas to the brain so he's very
interested in this question and then he
brings something up that that's quite
interesting he says all of this is not
going to appear at all strange to a
certain kind of people people who are
well informed well informed about what
he says those who know how wide a range
of different automata has self-moving
mechanisms or moving machines the skill
of a human being can make only using a
very few parts if we compare that now to
this complex machine that is the body
Descartes says and we think about the
infinite maker of it in this case God
right he says then you're going to
understand this is an incredibly complex
machine he says they will consider this
body as a machine which having been made
by the hand of God is incomparably
better order and has in itself more
amazing movements than any that can be
created by man so he's bringing up a
very interesting point here is he not
which is we human beings create machines
we are in effect the the animal that
makes machines right and then we
ourselves at least in terms of our body
our machines created by a yet greater
maker so are we maybe just machines then
there's the the key question that's the
the context that's setting this so he
says I dwelt on this issue to show
if there were such machines having
organs and outward shape of different
things we would interpret them in
different ways what are the different
things in this case so the question is
could machines created by human beings
replicate living beings and at the time
that they card is writing this of course
you know mechanics is rather
underdeveloped in comparison to today
and if you think about the the amazing
advances that we have made in robotics
in artificial intelligence in in just
you know reducing the size of electrical
circuits down to very very small
entities and even in what we call
machine learning perhaps it's not the
best term given what Descartes has to
say here because perhaps machines don't
actually learn in a significant sense
but if you think about how we represent
these things to ourselves is this more
plausible today that machines could in
fact replicate living beings you know we
make science fiction stories and movies
about this sort of thing we even have a
word replicant coming of course from
philip k dick Bladerunner where we're
talking about an artificial human being
made by human beings so this is a very
live issue Descartes says well when it
comes to animals just playing all the
animals take us out of the equation the
answer is yes now there wasn't a
possibility at his own time and it may
not in fact be a possibility yet for us
but if we adopt the Cartesian
perspective on animals which is
essentially that they already are just
meat and bone and nerve machines they
don't have anything besides that then
the answer is yes we could create new
machines like those as a matter of fact
the entire bodily process of
reproduction you know of cells
reproducing by using their
netic material to create new cells and
all that merely mechanical processes as
far as Descartes is concerned what about
human beings can we create something
that would mimic a human being so
successfully that eventually we would
have to say well it really is a human
being what if we took the human body and
we mapped it out perfectly and then we
constructed a machine on that basis he
says if there were machines having the
organs and outward shape of a monkey or
any other irrational animal we would
have no means of knowing they were not
of exactly the same nature as those
animals whereas if any machines
resembled us in body and imitated our
actions insofar as this was practically
possible that's a key line and so far as
this was practically possible which
nowadays covers an awful lot we would
still have to he says very certain means
of recognizing that they were not human
beings now these are also ways of
recognizing that animals other animals
the brute animals as they would have
called them back then are not the same
as human beings either you know we might
say in addition to something like a
Turing test maybe there could be an
animal version where a very very smart
chimpanzee you know either can or can't
fool us into thinking that it's a human
being or you know cetacean of some sort
or an octopus or pick whatever you like
so what are the key differences it's not
enough just to say oh well we're
rational animals and the other animals
are not rational what is that
rationality actually consistent what
does that mean you can't just invoke it
that's not solving the issue so
Descartes here is thinking about
something that's really at the core of
our rational nature the first sign that
he talks about is using language or
other modes of signs as
says and it's not enough just to be able
to you know say Polly wants a cracker or
something like that or for I don't know
your your there's these funny YouTube
videos where a dog is you know going
wrong and people are saying oh it sounds
like I love you right for decart all
those sorts of things are just signals
rather than signs as we might say they
don't signify thoughts they don't
signify something new so he says the
first criterion is that these machines
would never be able to use words or
other signs now it doesn't stop there
because I know some people are gonna
object and say wait a second Siri uses
words and signs all the time or relax or
whoever whatever personal assistant you
have on your phone or your your laptop
or you know whatever other mechanism you
have right Siri or whatever other thing
we can think of in this way going all
the way back to Eliza one of the first
artificial intelligence programs which
wasn't really artificial intelligence
but was set to mimic human beings says
things but are they really saying things
in the same way so he goes on he says
composing these signs as we do to
declare our thoughts to others is an
artificial construct actually declaring
its thoughts it's doing what its
programming tells it to do but it
doesn't actually have thoughts on its
own that it wants to convey to us as a
matter of fact this is something really
worth dwelling upon thoughts for dhikr
covers a wide range it's not just
propositions like you know the cat is on
the table or it's time now to feed the
dog or things along those lines dog has
real interest in telling you it's time
to feed the dog doesn't it it also
includes you know conveying desires
trying to act on other things right
thoughts covers a wide range so he says
we can well conceive of a machine made
in such a way it emits words and even
utters them about bodily actions which
bring about some corresponding change in
his organs so you touch it on a certain
spot he says it'll ask what we want if
you touch it somewhere else it'll cry
out that we're hurting it you know again
think about you know these these
personal assistants that we have that
are AIS you can you can ask them kind of
funny questions and they give funny
answers but they're not really conscious
they're just following programming it's
not like they come up with you know
original meanings or you know locutions
of their own so he says it's not
conceivable that the Machine would put
these words into different orders to
correspond to the meaning of things set
in its presence and this is something
that we notice even decart says that
most dull-witted person can do so
there's a sense in which language isn't
just about having a code where things
mean things it's also about a productive
capacity to use language to say
something new that's very important now
can animals do something like that
Descartes would say no perhaps this is
something where we would want to look
more carefully at animal behavior and
our contemporary theories of it but at
least for where Descartes is he's saying
no they can't do that the other key
criterion here of what it means to be
rational and how we can tell machines
that are imitating human beings apart
from human beings or animals that would
in some way be portrayed as being human
has to do he says with a capacity to do
many things you might talk about this in
terms of what we call transfer from one
domain to another this is why we can
actually learn why we have the
flexibility to move from one
next to the next to the next to the next
so he says although such machines
machines designed to imitate human
beings might do many things as well or
even better than any of us they wouldn't
inevitably fail to do some others by
which we would discover they did not act
consciously but only because their
organs were disposed in a certain way
their organs being essentially their
programming right says we can we can
take a machine and it could be really
really good at one thing or maybe ten
things but it's not going to be equally
good at everything else this is an
interesting criterion to bring up isn't
it in our own time when we have these
incredibly powerful computers that now
are doing many things quite well
Descartes is saying that you're never
going to have a computer that does
everything that a human being can do
well now he doesn't go into any great
detail about this but we might think
about difficult things that are in some
respect difficult to explain and at
least for some people difficult but
which don't seem to be too hard for most
of us but would be hard for a machine to
do even with the best
mimicking programming showing empathy to
another person is that something that a
robot who's great at putting together
cars is going to be able to do well I
mean these are open questions that we
can ask about Descartes thinks from from
his own time that this is not this is
not going to be possible for a machine
it's also not possible for an animal
animals do some things very well there's
other things that they they don't do
well or that they can't even do at all
he goes on and he says something that
really helps to inform all of this
reason he says is a universal instrument
reason is able to extend to in in theory
just about anything that we human beings
can come across
he says reason is a universal instrument
which can operate in all sorts of
situations machines however whether we
think about in terms of organs or
programming are designed for certain
things so he says it's practically
possible for there to be enough
different organs in a machine to cause
it to act in all life's occurrences in
the same way that our reason causes us
to act now this is assuming of course
that we're being reasonable that we're
not just following our own programming
coming to us from our society or our
genetics or whatever and and largely
oriented by the imagination as Descartes
would say and habit so he says we can
determine the difference between men and
animals in this way he says there's
there's a very remarkable fact there are
no human being so dull-witted and stupid
not even madmen that they're incapable
of stringing together different words
and composing them into utterances even
if they're crazy talk and he says this
this is not just a matter of organs
magpies parents can talk like we do but
it's not really talking as such it's not
communication and he says this shows us
animals don't just have less reason less
rationality than human beings they don't
have any at all they're just essentially
machines and he goes on to say that
animals show more skill and some of the
reactions than we do dogs are great at
say sniffing out you know drugs or
something right pigs sniff out truffles
our noses are actually rather
underdeveloped by by relation but we can
do so many other things that they can't
do including domesticating with dogs and
farming and eating the pigs so they're
using them to find truffles and using
them to find drugs it wouldn't have
occurred to them on their own most
likely so this is really an interesting
issue and I think in our own time just
to bring this to a close we might want
to called a cart into question on this
and
couldn't machines at some point pass a
threshold where they would be able to do
this and would be rational might animals
not participate at least certain higher
animals to a certain degree in this if
that's the case then Descartes would
actually be wrong at least in part
perhaps take heart is right though and
perhaps we are the only creatures that
we encounter so far that are capable of
this in which case we would be able to
tell human beings
apart from machines designed to imitate
an act like human beings
you